what I am doing and what I do on a
professional basis every day is I take
the mean culture world the mean world
prequel meme Star Wars memes I mean some
of the best memes out there are Star
Wars memes and you apply that to
politics and you are able to get an
intersectional point where you can get a
young kid or some young person who might
know Star Wars but doesn't quite
understand what's going on with
impeachment and you can frame it the
world for them based on Star Wars and
actually bring them into the political
process which is very important I'm Dave
Rubin and according to the Wikipedia
editors this is the Rubin report as
always guys make sure that you're
subscribed to our channel by clicking
subscribe over there and clicking that
notification bell and more importantly
joining me today is the chief creative
officer for Turning Point USA and meme
maker extraordinaire Mattie Johnson
fantastic it feels very clever do man
how is this taking so long to happen
you're a busy guy you're a busy guy yeah
busy guy going around the world Jordan
Peterson it's like you know like a cut
as IQ and a half they got me yeah you're
half of Peterson's brain that's a very
room-temperature IQ really temperature I
can use room temperature well I have
wanted you on for a while I'm glad we're
finally doing this and before you know
normally when I started interview I kind
of asked people their background a
little framing of the interview but I
thought first what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna throw to this video
that you just put up on Instagram this
is you going to this is outside of the
impeachment hearings yes outside of the
impeachment hearings you're asking
questions about politics and Trump and
impeachment all through the lens of a
little movie called Star Wars here we go
hey everyone Betty Johnson here at the
United States Capitol where the
impeachment trial of President Trump is
ongoing the Capitol has tens of leftist
protesters gathered at it calling for
the impeachment of President Trump
specifically we're asking them if Star
Wars references about President Trump
are worthy of having him be impeached
Senate we're going to see if these
leftist protesters believe that the
president should be impeached for
instance of killing a fictional general
General Grievous hello
I can't wait to hear what they have to
say let's go find out many people felt a
disturbance in the force when General
Grievous was killed what do you think
about the killing of General Grievous
and why you know was it right or wrong
okay uh nobody's saying that he was a
good person
but there are a lot of big people in the
world and we have lost everything what
we'll do is our military should be
according to law with new x-wing
technology though there's no there's no
telling what we could accomplish I mean
you can get anyone anywhere yes yes
absolutely
[Music]
do you think that it was right or not
right to kill General Grievous is
clearly an assassination people are
saying that a thermal detonator was used
for the assassination and these are very
dangerous weapons do you have anything
to say on that you seem to care a lot
about this this is just like the kind of
music that was being saying in moss
eisely cantina
it's beautiful and General Grievous was
killed by the administration by Trump
they were saying that was illegal do you
do you believe in those kind of killings
or do you not we have a rule of law if
that rule of law says if I think you're
a bad guy then I should be able to kill
you right that's not our rule of law I
killed them I killed them all a rule of
laws if I think you're a bad guy I'm
supposed to take you to trial and prove
that you are a bad guy that is our rule
of law in the United States of America
you can't
he must stand trial apparently he was
killed with a thermal detonator this is
like a lot of concerning to a lot of
people no and the rule of law either we
have it and we need to live by it both
the citizens and our government or we
don't and we don't give a crap one way
or the other my lord all right so that's
just a small portion of this video that
you put out there and I think now my
audience understands why I wanted to
throw that before we do anything else
here now that one gentleman at the end
did make a good point should we not have
taken General Grievous in and put him on
trial I mean he was the leader of the
separatist army he had just taken over
from now dude to Count Dooku who's a
horrible human being it's a good point
yeah I mean it's true I who knows I mean
if it was the Obama administration
definitely would have taken him out with
the drone would've never seen it happen
it you know it could have even been an
American citizen would have been boom
General Grievous gone wouldn't you do
these videos because I know most people
watch them are going oh come on he must
have had to go to a thousand different
people to get the five first five guys
four or five people
not a single I kept asking about General
Grievous and I you can see in the video
I keep like pushing them like people
felt in service in the force it's it's
very much a dark side to have this
technology with a thermal detonator and
x-wing technology to kill this general
no-one nothing I even say later in the
video that Trump should just execute an
order 66 and dissolve the Senate and
then you can just get rid of this
impeachment Fiasco what does this tell
you about these people before we get to
the Star Wars element of it and why Star
Wars memes really do Merrick what does
this tell you about a lot of the
activists that are out there and people
that are you know purporting to know
everything about politics I'm not even
talk about these five people
specifically them but these people that
are just out there protesting all the
time and then whenever you see them
challenge you know Crowder is really
good at this but just suddenly no no
nothing yeah so the purpose of a video
like this is never to actually make fun
of anyone what I'm trying to do is to
show that there is a bankruptcy when it
comes to the understanding of why we are
impeaching this president why do are
these people actually out there
protesting
person in the video is protesting for
Trump's impeachment yet even when asked
if they should impeach Trump for killing
General Grievous which was my question
should we impeach Trump for killing a
fictional Star Wars villain yeah they
said yeah and so what I am doing
and what I do on a professional basis
every day is I take the mean culture
world the mean world prequel meme Star
Wars means I mean some of the best memes
out there are Star Wars memes and you
apply that to politics and you are able
to get an intersectional point where you
can get a young kid or some young person
who might know Star Wars but doesn't
quite understand what's going on with
impeachment and you can frame it the
world for them based on Star Wars and
actually bring them into the political
process which is very important so what
is it about Star Wars because I mean the
hell out of Star Wars probably only
second to you right and there's
something particularly about the
prequels that the memes just you know
how does democracy die with under its
applause and I am the Senate and all of
those lines they seem so powerful right
now and it's like what what do you think
it is about Star Wars specifically that
leads to this where other movies you can
mean some things from other movies but
not like the endless amount from Star
Wars that just feels right for the
moment all the time
Star Wars was if you go if you rewind
the clock back to George Lucas he based
the Empire on Nazis and he based the
rebellion on fighting Nazis and so for
people like us
particularly you were able to find these
moral threads that you can pull out of
the basic Star Wars story the evil of
oppressive overarching brutalist
government how it tries to squash hope
how hope must rise in order to fight
that greatest evil which is an
oppressive overarching massive usually
by emergency powers government that can
take over all of our lives and that is
the the truth that this was based on and
I think it hits at a human truth truth
that goes all the way back to our
founding and much of the Renaissance
good that comes from the idea that man
is man and man wants
freedom and man has liberties that
should not be corrupted and oppressed by
a government well it's funny because
even though you're doing it in a funny
way there we could talk about the idea
that should the Jedi have captured
Grievous he was the leader of the
separatist army right so he was an
insurgent but should they have been
allowed to just kill him as obi-wan did
or should they have captured him and
taken River trial that actually is an
interesting philosophical point that we
debated all the time because that's to
your point that when we killed Soleimani
everyone was saying well you can't just
kill the guy you have to bring him in
for a trial or the rest of it that I
mean that really all does add up to why
memes work yes correct
memes are a piece of non corporate non
establishment media imagery that
reflects a moment in culture and reflect
something that we're all going through
and explains it in a very simple and
shareable way I want pretty sure we
could do the Star Wars thing the entire
way so let's let's just do a little bit
more the case there's anyone out there
watching this that doesn't have the
appreciation of the Star Wars meme
meeting point that we do you mentioned
something really interests me right
before we started about how the way the
Star Wars movies have progressed or
regressed I suppose which depending on
which way you look at it is is really
reflective of internet culture in
general can you talk about that because
I think it's really super interesting we
as consumers of the product have more
value than we have ever had in the
history of the creation of a thing
so you've democratized the consumer base
for things like Star Wars and Star Wars
The Phantom Menace has actually saved
Star Wars from itself if Menace I got
the Phantom Menace is a real thing and
we can the feedback mechanisms are now
available in a decentralized universe
where the studio's have to listen to the
consumers and where we are able to
online demand something or ask for
something or consume at a rate where
it's a feedback loop instead of them
just making a Star Wars and
when we like it they make a Star Wars
then we tell them if we like it right
you can hear what happened after the
last Jedi and the studio heard it yeah
and then desperately JJ comes in to try
to like fix it and there are four to
five different moments in the rise of
Skywalker where they papered over yeah
what Ryan did and that's because of the
response online and so this mechanism
can actually make you more powerful than
Studios producing these things and the
general I love democracy the democracy
of the fandom is actually a wonderful
thing Palpatine would be very proud yeah
Palpatine would be thrilled that
Internet basically it's really
interesting I mean that concept is
actually kind of cool because you know
Studios come out with with certain
things that often are not good and I
think the best of the best version of
this in terms of internet culture is the
the all-female Ghostbusters it had
nothing to do with it all being women
but it was a patently terrible movie yes
and then the audience goes crazy and
then you get the next layer of this
which I want to talk to you about which
is suddenly the media that runs
protection for bad movies right and then
starts attacking the audiences and
that's what happened in ghostbusters
we saw that happen in last Jedi to where
they say it's it's all angry white male
trolls who hate last Jedi or hate
ghostbusters and it's racist Trump
supporters who hate these things and
it's the media then attacking the fan
base I don't know is it at the behest of
the studio or is it just because the
whole machine just kind of works like
that or what I think it has everything
to do with what's going on in society
right now I cover politics but the
election in 2016 was precisely this
bubble the same thing that happens with
a Star Wars movie or Ghostbuster happen
in 2016
where you have a group of people that
are so insulated in their own virtue
signaling and woke division and
slacktivism and they must insert that
into everything in their lives and it
blinds them to understanding what an
actual normal consumer wants and so then
you have the rise of something a real
anger that the things that we cherish
are being destroyed and one of the last
few good things out there was Star Wars
and from both sides you have this
kind of y'all this anger from the base
when we watched the last Jedi and
realize that it's now just a serving
dish for someone's political worldview
and you must eat it and it's like damn
it no I mean the orcs are not just add
the gate they've like come in and they
desecrated the temple one of the last
few things that we actually all could
come together on was that we all kind of
loved Star Wars and then that's
destroyed and you're gonna get backlash
this happened in 2016 you've got the
election of President Trump and this is
happening now when it comes to our
entire culture whether that be Star Wars
or Ghostbuster or national politics what
do you think about the idea that because
big studios now run so much of our
entertainment that that also has fed all
of this like the Star Wars posters look
exactly like the Marvel posters you know
what I mean it's always the same thing
the big guy in the middle its Iron Man
in the middle or Rey in the middle and
that everybody else smaller after and
they look exactly same like the branding
is the same the messages start becoming
the same that we don't have new stories
anymore and again I said you right
before you start I hate to say that in a
way because it's like I want these
stories to continue and Mandalorian was
totally fine and like I want more out of
this but it's also like we need
something different like the world has
moved on from George Lucas having to
look at World War 2 to then create these
characters you know yeah and that is
something that I think people are very
much hungry for on a national level and
you're watching now people running for
speaking of news stories I mean look at
the number of people who have never been
in politics that are now running and
winning and becoming very very famous I
don't know well great not only see all
right I don't like AOC in the squad yeah
I I think they're going to wreck the
country if you give them power but but
listen they have become heroes now
because there's a new story there's a
new narrative out there and of course
the opposite of that would be you know
multiple people who have never had any
experience on the conservative side of
the aisle running for office and
following a trumpian model of I am the
outsider and these new stort that the
idea that there's a new story out there
really gravitates it really brings
people in and again you have a president
who's pretty much our version of that
elected outside of them elected outside
of the media bubble outside of the group
think that occurs inside of the Acela
corridor between DC and New York and the
groupthink said every like every Marvel
poster looked like every poll looked
exactly the same in 2016 every poll
Hillary Clinton nine remember the
Huffington Post
98% chance Hillary will win right take
to the bank you've seen the same
compilations I have and so it's like
every poster looks the same and people
start rejecting it and wanting a new
story and now you have arguably I mean
very easily the most powerful man in the
world the president the United States
has been elected because people were so
desperate and hungry for a news story
and not and rejecting the same stuff
that's been forced on us for decades
alright so before we go too far into the
Trump thing and I want to talk
impeachment and how this is all related
to media and all that now let's go to
where I usually start the interviews
which is how the hell did you get into
this whole thing like what brought benny
johnson to sit here right now and talk
to me about star wars I was raised in
Iowa and I was a magical place where you
can really see candidates up close you
get to one of the things that we force
every candidate who wants to be
President to do is eat pork chop on a
stick you want to dehumanize someone and
you really want to break them down to
their core elements right like for
someone like Hillary Clinton to eat a
pork chop on a stick and a 120 degree
humid day in the middle of the I was
never that picture of Michelle Bachman
the corn dog Romney trying it like
Romney was one of the words no one looks
good eating a corn dog yeah no one looks
good eating a sweaty pork chop on a
stick yeah did you grow up going to
those fairs and yet I go into the straw
balls in the rest of it yeah so you got
to see the real human being behind the
politician you got to see like the
little quirks little things bit of them
like they would take as a young guy in
politics I was just in student
government at my college and at my high
school you would get taken out to subway
by a MIT Romney right he would take you
out the subway you get to watch the man
eat his Subway sandwich you get to see
the human side of the politician and was
something that was always lacking
because they always came off as such a
stiff veneer right when you see him on
stage and so I began to really gravitate
towards telling stories differently for
the political class and inside of the
political bubble and that began a career
in making viral content about politics
I've done this for now over a decade and
I've always wanted to bring and mesh the
worlds that a lot of young people
understand which is the cultural world
and mesh that in with politics that
people understand the political world
around them because quite frankly that's
the most important thing you can
understand as an American so as an Iowa
guy yeah is it shocking or strange or
backwards or is it the way it's supposed
to be that in just a few weeks this
straw poll which seems so antiquated and
ridiculous in so many ways
is the thing that is going to set the
next eight months in motion really yep
you know we're just in the lead-up we're
in pre-season right now still even
though it all feels crazy but the straw
poll starts this whole thing and someone
could get momentum out of nowhere and
you know if I didn't doze really bad
he's no longer the front-runner and
there it does that seem crazy to you as
someone that grew up in Iowa it's it's
like the various gladiator feats of
strength okay like to get there
federalism I mean it's one of the last
cherished things of federalism is that
you every state is different and the way
that this was supposed to work is every
state was supposed to be their own
actual governance and they the states
wouldn't have even you know come
together and signed the Constitution if
we didn't write as in the libertarian
you know this very firm grounds of
federalism that each state was unique I
was which we're washing away very
quickly very quickly horrifyingly yeah
horrifyingly so Iowa you you're gonna
have to go eat pork chop on a stick and
appeal to Iowans to get the Iowan vote
New Hampshire you're gonna have to go
and what do they do in New Hampshire tap
a maple maple tree get like the special
ski slope maple tree like vote yeah I
don't what New Hampshire I'm not from
there don't know much about it right
then I'm not condemning Iowa in any way
which is like the process like it's
always the same order every year like it
almost seems like we have to mix up the
order like because then it all just
becomes so entrenched that the fakery is
is too obvious or something like that I
I don't know much about why the process
is what it is I know that every yeah but
it is special that you have to go and
you have to earn the vote of a specific
group of people living in a specific
state and appeal to them and I love that
process I think it's great yeah you want
to make a crazy prediction that Iowa a
good Bernie I was gonna ask you some
predictions at the end really Bernie so
are you feeling this thing right now
because there does seem to be like a
certain momentum for for Bernie right
now like that the mainstream media has
really tried to take him out now again I
know you and I were not fans of his
ideas let's say but the major media has
just been going after the guy
relentlessly at war and tried some stuff
and you know women aren't gonna be
elected in the rest of it but do you
feel like he's just got this thing
whether the DNC wants it to happen or
not
yeah and Joe Rogan one of your colleague
you know one of the people who are so so
special in this in this decentralized
media industry kind of said it the best
which is the guy's just been a communist
his whole life and he just told everyone
about his communism forever and that
sort of authenticity is really valuable
now authenticity is the currency of the
internet people know if you're being
fake and people know if you're putting
on a show and when someone like Bernie
who's just an old crusty communist who
has just been an old crusty communist
his entire life honeymoon in the Soviet
Union let's not forget when he comes
into an age that's Internet centric then
his authenticity really shines through
and people really have really gravitate
to that it's the same thing that brought
a lot of people over to trump and it's
this thing that is really I think
driving the boom right now for Bernie
that is putting him now up ahead double
digits in New Hampshire up ahead almost
double digits in Iowa I think that that
like I am the same guy that I've always
been is something that is more
attractive now than ever
well that's a funny thing
about the Rogen endorsement it's like
just saying that someone hasn't changed
it's an init of itself so great but I
get you there's there's a consistency
there I suppose that people like but you
may have all the wrong ideas within that
yes but authenticity I mean people will
gravitate towards something authentic
more than ever today and it's because
we've been trained to do this based on
what we like on social media the
authenticity that we see into people's
lives and we now have access into
everyone's life people can figure out
what Dave Rubin likes these people can
follow you on social media and see the
things about you and I know yeah and see
what you love and what you hate and they
can tell if you're an authentic person
and we are now demanding that inside of
our politicians and like it or not
that's part of the reason why people
just adore the president the United
States right now is because there's no
lying with him you're gonna hear his
unvarnished opinions regardless of
whether you love them or not you're
going to see directly inside of his
brain and what's going on and you're
gonna find that out through his social
media and through Twitter and that's
what endears so many Americans to that
we've been trained to want that alright
so how the hell does Trump understand
all this stuff I have asked a million
guests this everyone has their own
theory but how does Trump get the meme
Wars the edge Lords the trolls the
Russians the whole damn thing how does
Trump get it
I think you've a little insight maybe
into what he's thinking or you've been
around him enough and the turning point
world Trump has always been a creature
of the media he's always very much
understood media and every era that he's
lived in from the 70s 80s 90s to today
he's understood media and how people
consume information where is the
audience and he's always understood
audience now we have to ask yourself if
you're talking about the modern media
landscape what is a media company the
media companies were the audiences and
Trump has very elegantly navigated to
the place where the audience is every
single iteration of his career and it's
been very very special to watch how
guy at 70 years old has just mastered
the meme wars and just mastered the art
of social media and a new generation of
kids that's where they are that's where
they're getting their information do you
think the world was just waiting for
someone like him like it didn't actually
have to be him but that because of
everything you're talking about in the
way that things have changed and we
watch mainstream media crumble and the
internet rise and all that but it was
gonna be somebody to do this reckoning
and he just happened to be the guy or do
you think that that really is unique
about him the way he the lens that he
used the world because of the way he
survived media over decades and all that
yeah I think we're living in the Golden
Age of memes and politics and Trump has
brought that about and the world was
waiting for someone to create the diad
in the force that was the president I'm
gonna see how many more stories you can
force in here let's see force in here I
love what you just did there Dave you
the world was waiting for the internet
president right the president who fully
understood the internet and brought it
with him to the White House and Barack
Obama bringing in YouTube celebrities
that's one thing but Barack Obama was
not the internet president not at all
the internet president is Donald Trump
who hosts the social media summit at the
White House I had the honor of being
invited to it you walk into the foyer of
the White House I mean famous Bentall
Hollywood movies it's you know from the
time of Lincoln and they're huge memes
printed out on boards painting in the
grand foyer of the White House made like
this is this is the world I've been
begging for my entire career
you walk around look there's a mean and
there's a game of Thrones meme and it
they're all bear likes hanging inside of
the most sacred house in America right
the most cherished and valuable piece of
real estate in the country is the White
House one of those recognizable places
on planet Earth is the White House and
here are memes hanging inside of the
grand foyer of the White House this is
actually the Internet president I think
it's really fundamental that Trump gets
audience he understands where an
audience is and right now today
there has been a dynamic shift in where
people actually are and where people are
our platforms and where they want to get
their information our platforms and from
influencers and Trump that's the biggest
influence are out there so the last time
that we actually saw each other in
person was at the turning-point student
action summit about a week before
Christmas couple days before Christmas I
spoke that morning you you you were sort
of the emcee of the whole thing right
you're shooting t-shirts into the crowd
and you're getting everybody going but
you didn't warm up the crowd for me that
morning well what you were doing that
Saturday morning I wasn't gonna bring
this up I don't know what happened I did
okay that's not even the point I did
just find the point is that I spoke in
the morning and then and then Trump
spoke later in the afternoon and it was
and then when he spoke he was the first
time that I ever ever heard him speak
live and and it did help crystallize one
thing for me which is how the media
takes an hour and a half speech that he
gives and how they really extrapolate
whatever they want out of it because
there's a moment that I'm sure you
remember where Trump gets up there and
he goes he goes I know more about
windmills than anybody I've been with my
whole life and then he goes on this riff
about windmills now obviously he doesn't
know more about windmills and everybody
obviously he's not studying windmills
but he makes some interesting points
about how they build windmills and all
of this other stuff but then I saw it
happened so he does the speech and he
sort of basically like a comic and he's
working the room and he kind of goes off
script and then comes back but then it
was the next part and this is where I
really had all kind of crystallized for
me was then later that afternoon what do
I see of course Vox media matters the
rest of it with all of their headlines
Donald Trump claims he knows more about
windmills than anybody Donald Trump
claims he studied windmills his whole
life and it's like did he say that he
did is that in context No do you
understand sarcasm no yes and it's like
when you when you really see it that way
it did shift the whole thing for me to
actually be there and then see the
headlines yes there is such a thing as
sarcasm humor still in the world it's
not literate it's not literal bit
literal right literally not both
actually yeah but a good meme is
something that takes it that is funny
that uses Hugh
uses pop culture to connote a greater
truth about the world around us and
Donald Trump speaks and memes so what a
lot of people I don't think understand
yeah is that this arrow was actually
made for him when Donald Trump looks
Hillary Clinton in the eye and goes
because you'd be in jail
that's like an impact fought me that was
a meme right like that was one of the
most memorable maybe perhaps the most
memorable if you play it on a big screen
to an audience which I do regularly the
most memorable moment in 2016 and that
was Trump just speaking in a meme sure
sentences understandable dialogue joke
right sarcasm but hitting a deeper truth
and that's the way the president speaks
and the hyper literal perpetually
wanting to be offended corporate media
that exists today they don't they don't
get them but at their peril because
Trump is speaking the way that the
Internet speaks and the way the
consumers speak and the way that the
audiences of the future speak and the
audiences of the future want to get
their information from memes I give this
speech around the country tens of
thousands of students around the country
I speak to every single year and it's a
huge privilege of mine to do that but I
ask them with regularity where would you
prefer to get your information raise
your hand if you want to get your
information from a meme if you would
prefer it in that form and thousands of
hands go I'm telling you Dave thousands
of hands go up from the students I take
a cell phone out of my pocket I do this
thought prompt just thought test all the
time take a cell phone out of my pocket
put on the table and I say this cell
phone is yours it's free you can get it
free of charge one rule locked it coated
in to the actual iPhone brand new is
that you can only download one app to
get your news and information from what
happened you download it
I asked kids this doesn't matter if it's
fifty kids in a small room or 500 kids
or 5,000 kids it's always the same I'm
guessing the answer is Twitter right
don't tell me it's tick tock and I'm
gonna jump in here but it's a mix a lot
of instagrams I would say probably eight
out of ten is
Instagram that's a first again these are
school-aged kids their school-aged kids
eight out of ten is an Instagram you
always have your outliers will say
reddit it's maybe you know very rarely
about Facebook
you get YouTube a lot of youtubes and
some Twitter's it kind of depends on the
diet of the students sure here's
something that never ever ever set ever
MSNBC yeah
CNN well CNN when I give a speech to
college kids CNN sometimes I say
something about CNN not to be funny I'm
like you know CNN is one channel and and
they laugh when I say CNN as it backs a
bunch it's so excited to them you know I
don't think it's even partisan Dave I
they they don't say Fox News either they
want to get their information from and
I'm just gonna be complimentary here you
from a decentralized non corporate
influencer who is going to bring them
the information that they trust you they
trust guys like me they trust
influencers they want
we are the new nightly news anchors then
lot of memes are our new news program
right and the new broadcast network are
these platforms that they can follow us
on and see more of a dimensionality of
us and the world around them and that's
how they prefer to get their information
isn't it amazing so obviously I agree
with you and the broad says there it's
like all the mainstream media then had
to do was sort of incorporate some of us
and instead of trying to destroy all of
us which is what they chose to do
instead right they decided to say we're
all bigots and racists and all all the
rest of it and try to crush our jobs and
crush our reach on top of big tech and
everything else but all I had to do was
bring on a couple guys ABC all they
probably had to do or its forget ABC CNN
and you know six years ago your phone
could have rang and they could have been
like can you be the guy that takes us
into the the new thing Benny and and
then maybe they wouldn't be in this
situation and yet that tells you about
the archaic nature of the Machine
there's an industry story about
blockbusters valuation and neve al
uation you've seen the same chart that
I've seen blockbuster could have buried
Netflix for a decade of Netflix's
existence mm-hmm but instead they chose
to laugh at them and they said we're
we're blockbuster he's gonna
these people right this woman no one
ever wants a DVD in the mail this is not
a problem and now we are looking at
20/20 and Netflix is winning Golden
Globes and may win Oscars this year
right and nothing there one blockbuster
there's one left in Alaska it's in
Alaska yes is that right yes that's why
there's this there's this inflection
point where the industry where your
industry is overtaking and people no
longer need gas lanterns they are you
worried about that though does any level
of that worry you
so something that is been interesting
about the D masking of corporate media
specifically on places like places like
CNN is that you're able to see in the
era of Trump who they always were you're
able to see like a viral clip that's
going around right now is this clip of
Don LeMond we're gonna we're gonna play
the Clarion so you know why don't we
play this clip yeah sure I met this clip
is from about a week to go I mentioned
this when I had Michael malleus on last
week we did a little of dissection but I
think it would be great to get your
dissection as to so this is this is Don
lemons CNN program and obviously it's
false and look he also knows deep in his
heart that Donald Trump couldn't find
Ukraine in a map if you had the letter U
and a picture of an actual physical
crane next to it he knows that this is
you know an administration defined by
ignorance of the world and so that's
partly him playing to their base and
playing to their audience you know the
the the credulous Boomer Rube demo that
backs Donald Trump that wants to think
that that that dog Trump's the smart one
in there Oh y'all y'all elitist er you
would lead us with your geography in
your maps and your spelling given though
my path reading yeah you're reading you
know your geography no in other
countries sipping your latte all those
lines on the map only they may lead us
nowhere Ukraine is sorry I apologize
it was Rick's fault
I blame Rick you're not
no it's good sorry right yeah that was a
good what I needed that
it's so deeply fake the laughter is fake
nobody's laughing that hard at that joke
the banter is fake the whole damn thing
fake right news so someone said fake
news somewhere at one point why so why
should you be why should you be that
rightfully makes a lot of people angry
that clip but why you should be
encouraged by that clip actually is that
it happened a week before it really went
viral so few people were watching Don
LeMans show that no one even noticed
yeah they were just screaming into the
abyss they were screaming into the woods
and that the tree fell and no one heard
it and I know for a fact I know for a
fact cuz I can pull the Nielsen ratings
but good videos that we make a turning
point get more viewers yeah then CNN's
entire nightly Linna
this show yeah Dave Rubens show yeah
gets more viewers per video than many
headline news shows on CNN you good
video with you and Shapiro and Peterson
will get more viewers than CNN's entire
ratings the whole week for a month
probably yes ran some cases yeah and so
what it what is this inflection point
it's really special
it shows the one thing that is so
important in media's audience where is
your audience who has it and where is
the audience going and the fact that
that can happen and no one even knows
that it's happening because so few
people are watching this news show let's
remember it's make you sick to your
stomach that's a news show yeah
that's listed as a that's in the CNN
line up the on LeMans show yeah I I know
you don't say it Don Lamanna angry so
it's funny yeah
that's how depressing it is and if you
if you're looking young people are not
watching that people that are the clip
would have gone viral instantly if
people had actually been watching the
show but what do you make of the the
cognitive dissonance of these people the
same people who said the deplorable the
thrusting Trump to victory are now doing
that making fun of people's accents
making fun of people's education all of
those things yeah when it's like what
let's say these people are let's pretend
for a moment that they're less educated
and that's why they're voting for Trump
aren't you supposed to be a good lefty
who would want to help educate these
people I mean yeah the the smugness of
it is I think the most you know I get
the media side of it but it's the
detachment from what they purport to
believe yeah politically or
philosophically that I find were
disturbing so that's going back to
authenticity being the concern the the
currency of the internet people want to
know where their information is coming
from I am a conservative you are a
libertarian people understand that who
are tuning into this show and that's
okay
the D masking is showing clips like that
or they are now unvarnished presenting
themselves as the leftist propagandists
that they actually are and that veneer
of objectivity has been utterly
destroyed that the car the the the
carpet has been rent the the curtain has
been ripped there is no such thing as
objectivity anymore and that's okay as
long as you're prepared for the new
thing coming which is this which is
understanding that Dave Rubin is a
libertarian and he's gonna come at it
from a libertarian point of view that's
okay yeah I know and you're also gonna
watch us work through it in real - yes
which is one of the things that's why I
do the events that I always do a turning
point where I go up there and I always
make a point of saying guys I'm gonna
say a few things that I know most of you
disagree with and not only do I get
invited back but if anything I think
that's why I'm getting invited in the
first place yeah so you're one of those
popular speakers and maybe have maybe
40% of your speech is not necessarily
the exact thing that the audience
believes that's okay they want half of
my speech last night was about Star Wars
because they just come out the funny
thing is I ended up I didn't want to
lead too much remember so I was like I
wasn't talking too much about Star Wars
then we do Q&A and I always say to them
kids I'm all kids students whatever I
always say if you disagree with me come
up first and yet all the questions were
about Star Wars and I was like wait guys
let me get this straight I give a
political speed the President of the
United States is speaking here in an
hour and you're asking me about Star
Wars and everyone was like crazy is why
you gotta ask
questions about general grievous right
that's why you have to use star wars use
the billions that have been put in to
tell leading the Star Wars story to tell
a story about politics about the things
that are going on in the world today and
people that really understand that or
the people that understand where
audience is going and this is where
audience is going whether they can they
can laugh they can laugh and they can be
Nero and and and strum write the harp
while Rome burns which is what I get
when I watch a clip like that when I
watch a clip like that I think about
Rome burning and about neuro playing his
harp mm-hmm and I think that's just them
laughing and cackling being the last
little ëletís on their little pedestals
as their ratings are crumbling as their
advertising dollars are going through
the floor and as people are tuning out
in record numbers and as they're being
background quite literally on a daily
basis that is that is Rome burning do
you ever think when one of these clips
is going viral and again I think you
made a really interesting point that
this existed for a while before it went
viral which shows you that no one is
really watching this stuff but do you
ever think maybe we should just let it
be and I shouldn't jump in on it on
every clip because sometimes I feel that
because you know you see these things
happening on Twitter and you see
everyone kind of doing their thing and
making it bigger and then there's this
other part of me that's like you know
what if we all just started ignoring all
of this that we could really be maybe
better focused on whatever it is that we
individually are trying to build rather
than taking that thing down mm-hmm do
you think about that ever well you
brought it up that you're attacked they
call you a racist or Nazi for being on
something other than a corporate media
platform right instead of inviting us in
an hour and having to do the hard thing
which is diversity of opinion mm-hmm
actually lean in to diversity of opinion
they do the thing that losers do I'm not
saying that in the sense of like losers
I'm saying that in source of these are
tactics of people that are losing
they're losing their base and they're
losing their cultural war and when you
see them cackling about Trump supporters
and mocking accents and southern accents
and things like that
mocking people's careers and job that's
the tactic of a loser
that's not the tactic of a winner that's
the tactic of a losing side that's
attempting to score cheap points on
someone who's already defeated them
right like who are you bringing over
when you're doing that does anyone watch
that and go oh these guys they really
get it like I guess yeah there's the
sliver of the rice that's in on the joke
or something yeah but do you get anyone
anyone that they would want to bring
over to them I am thrilled when Liberals
slide it right into my diem and pop then
talk about how much they hate me and my
content and this happens of course you
know this this happens on a
minute-by-minute basis but if my content
is reaching them the Star Wars video
pisses off a ton of people right you
tricked them into thinking General
Grievous around he was killed in Iran
you also kiss up the star you're ruining
Grievous it's like everyone's reasons
you know thermal detonator wasn't used
to kill general Chris right like what
are you thinking if you can if if I can
just bring you into the conversation if
I could just just bring you into the
conversation and we can start that
dialogue that's a huge success for me so
as a conservative and a relatively young
conservative are you kind of shot
relatively happy I don't know you want
to say how old you are I'm 33 33 ancient
a pretty book Brooke but for a
conservative you know what I mean I
thought was you know if you listen to
MSNBC conservatives are supposed to be
stodgy old yeah so as a relatively young
conservative though are you are you
shocked how sort of wide the
conservative tent is becoming right now
yeah well I mean look at look at
conservative heroes right viral heroes
let's start off you have Ben Shapiro
like he comes from a very specific very
unique minority worldview right with
Orthodox Judaism
you've Candace Owens mmm coming from a
very specific very very much like a
worldview that is almost dinah dinah
dinah dinah and to itself yeah right
like I like you you're not able to mix
people like Andy no who's doing the best
reporting on an Tifa Scott Pressler
mm-hmm it the the young
roster of conservative heroes is so
diverse it really is gives you hope for
the future
I work with Charlie Kirk every single
day I know he's been on this show
yeah and it's amazing to think like my
god he's 26 so something interesting
happened a couple months ago there
started to be this like rise of what I
would say you're genuinely sort of
far-right people that were going after
Charlie going after turning-point showed
up to my events probably showed up to
things you were doing and one of the
things that I was super impressed by was
the level of fight that I saw people on
the right fighting these people yeah
where what I see on the left in my
audience knows how I feel about this
already obviously that the left there's
nothing too far left right Ilhan Omar's
not left enough and sorry sores not too
left and it's now you're never too left
or bananas to be associated with all
that Sam but the right does set limits
yes and I think that was pretty damn
impressive I say bye you guys because
because it was a real attack on
turning-point yeah and it didn't and you
guys fought back and I would I would say
won in whatever the hell Shapiro was
there to help I mean Ben gave it then
gave I think very Churchillian speech
right to really like break it all down
Charlie did this multiple places
business I knew it was a sudden group of
like I would say like real race focus
yeah
nationally something like I think that's
what separates us from the left though
is having the courage to say you're not
part of our party we disown you
right we disown you and these views we
do not want inside of our tent yeah by
the way did you see that I'm sure you
saw it that Stelter clip on CNN where
they show these these like race realists
protesting Donald Trump jr. with Charlie
on stage with them they're attacking
Trump jr. Trump treaters fighting
against the racists right now guys that
are screaming about all this stuff and
then CNN says Trump juniors fighting
against the conservatives like something
was something like the real
conservatives or something right they to
imply that real conservatives are racist
and it's somehow Trump Tudor was sort of
the good guy or like it's all so
confusing it's it's too confusing but
it's very basic element which is that if
you are a racist or if you are an ant
semi you have no quarter in my movement
those are things that I don't play
footsie with and we will disown you and
if those are the things that if that's
your worldview then that's not going to
be part of the movement that we are
creating and it's as simple as that CNN
can try and conflate that and people can
try and complate that all they want but
it's just it's just really clear and
when you lay out the words that are
being said and what is being said it's
it's really stark but it takes bravery
to do a thing like that and it also
takes a little bit of moral courage and
it'd be really exciting to watch that
type of a disown meant of anti-semitism
and of the views that play footsie with
or just openly embrace terrorist regimes
and anti-semitic tropes to happen on the
left to have it on both sides isn't this
one of the few things we should agree on
well that's why the the thing that
happened with Rogen was so crazy it's
like you've got you've got lefties
screaming that Bernie has to disown Joe
Rogan but he doesn't have to disown
Linda Sarsour yes disown Ilhan or a
Rashida to leb who's out on the campaign
trail with him Ottoman campaign trail
with him on a regular basis someone who
says the Holocaust gives are a calming
feeling yeah this is just shocking that
drogon is the guy who needs to be deep
sixed yeah we think that's always going
to embrace Michael Moore and we're going
to you know literally communist Michael
Moore communist aoc and open anti-semite
Rashidah to lab and Ilhan Omar let's
let's shift a little bit to this
impeachment thing have you heard about
this yeah that's something going down
you know what's funny is that I live in
DC I've lived in DC for ten years I made
my bones in Washington and I like being
close to my subject matter right it's
very important to understand how these
people tick behind the scenes so I have
a very firm pulse on DC in Washington
and how it works I pride myself in this
I set myself to you wouldn't know in
teach what's going on in Washington
you can sense when something big is
happening Kavanaugh for instance this is
an example of the entire city being in
raptured by a thing that's happening
that affects us all you can't go to a
coffee shop and you can't take the metro
without seeing Kavanagh
without hearing about it without having
someone come up and talk to you about it
people yelling in the streets people
screaming on both sides
ripping signs that's the thing that
takes over the entire city impeachment
it's like nothing like the government
took a xanax like everyone's out cold it
feels like the producers sort of like
it's a show that nobody's going exactly
but it's like a show that they wanted to
fail that then became the success it's
gonna be a spring time for Hillary
tomorrow springtime for Hitler but
that's not quite the right analogy there
but but you know I I can tell you why
you're right because when when I was on
tour with Peterson we were it was the
middle of the cabinet thing and we were
doing a Q&A in Ireland and people were
asking us about the cabinet thing and I
thought how bananas is this I'm in
Dublin and people can ask Jordan
anything they want and they're asking
him his thoughts on the Supreme Court
justice the potential Supreme Court
justice of the United States like that
has no bearing on their lives whatsoever
there's a million other things that this
guy could talk about that would you know
directly affect but it's like I don't
think anyone over there is talking about
it because nobody's taught my neighbor I
kid you not I was walking the dog the
other day the neighbor came up to me and
he you know he knows what I am and what
I do and he was like so how about that
impeachment thing and the way he laughed
was like I don't even know what his
political feelings are but he laughed as
if like like it's just like you would
say it to somebody it doesn't mean
anything but it's like saying what's the
weather like you know it was just like
that's it it's catastrophic if you look
at the polling if you look at Democrat
voters they don't care and then much
less and if you want to put a bow on
this whole thing what is the set what is
establishment corporate media been
covering non-stop 24/7 wall-to-wall
since October impeachment they have been
making the case and doing their best
many of them propagandists for the DNC
making their best case for Pietschmann
of President Trump and a guy like me who
has a show where I go out into the
streets and talk with people I went out
into the streets in Florida swing state
very political state and asked people if
they had been convinced or if they even
knew why the president was being
impeached
and the responses I got in two straight
hours of asking probably four or five
dozen people but was no I mean quite
frankly no they don't
they haven't been convinced they don't
really understand why it's happening and
all of the full force and weight of full
establishment media and everything
they've built in their entire kingdoms
come together to cover one thing and no
one cares and no it's not getting
through yeah and it's not making sense
but you know it does fly like a meme on
my Instagram about how stupid
impeachment is right and General
Grievous yeah yeah is are you worried
putting aside the reasons that you enjoy
the meme or is and everything else I
mean are you worried that even if Trump
wins that the the stage has been set
here that they'll just try another
impeachment after this and they'll just
try another that sort of the the ship
has sailed
they've said this is the route we're
going yeah they're saying you know now
the new thing is he's not gonna he won't
leave the presidency and that's another
reason we have to impeach him he won't
leave right I mean they're the ones that
won't accept the last election like
there's so many backwards you know they
usually tell you more about themselves
when they're claiming what what Trump
will or won't do but are you worried
about that just for the health of the
Republic I'm worried about that actually
that let's say Trump wins again which I
suspect he will and that if that happens
that we then just get another four years
of this and will ultimately have had six
years of just endless nonsense and then
how do you ever get out of that how do
you get out of it then as I said I had
Michael Dallas on last week he loves it
he says we should be in that all the
time because he likes the energy of that
but you but you as a as an energy guy
like through the internet do you does
that worry you there's no energy there
that's what's crazy about being in
Washington being on the ground is that
there there really is no energy there
something happened this last week two
big things impeachment March for Life
March for Life had hundreds of thousands
of people at it that city's a nightmare
the city's catastrophic at the March for
Life whether Trump speaks or not Trump
spoke katha struck can't get any work I
mean it's it's easier to find a lifeboat
on the Titanic then to try to find an
open uber or two font try and get
anywhere in the messed up grid that the
Marshall it because there's so
many people in the city there were
multiple impeachment protests I covered
them
it was legitimately pens of people
showing up I can tell you honestly I'm
not trying to make fun of them I can
tell you honestly less than a hundred
people showed up to each of these and
impeach pro-impeachment rallies it is
not something that it's not something
that there really is any energy at on
that on that level on the grassroots
level and polling shows this polling
shows that Democrat voters are like just
get it over with just get it over with
let's move on this isn't helpful do you
think the Democratic Party survives this
thing I actually think this might be the
end of the Democratic Party as we know
it and it's gonna split into something
else after this well I mean with your
past you wouldn't perhaps no better than
maybe box but I so I have I have usually
been right that's not all with these
people I I suspect that they cannot
survive this thing this this will
unearth all of the stuff it will cause
the the more radical socialists to go
their way and and the blue dogs are all
gone anyway but like whatever the decent
whatever you're a decent liberal this
has nothing to do with you anymore so
decent liberal was such a great point
that you just brought up decent liberal
yeah Pete Buddha judge viral clip this
week about him dunking you know dunking
on this pro-life democrat yeah Democrats
Catholic right you're pro-life if you're
Catholic so there's that a terrible
actually basically said is there room
for me
yes in the party as a pro-life democrat
I said get out and he's nice about it
yeah at the Buddha judge Mike guy he
said get out our party leave this is not
the tactics of a winning movement so
take it step back and look at tactics of
people who win they can allow diversity
they can allow a diversity of thought
they can be open to the world as it is
and they wish to attract more they wish
to bring in more like let's let's create
and let's get unique and let's come up
with new stories right the tactic of a
loser is people who have to censor or
control speech people who are horrified
of new ideas people that are dogmatic in
their belief system politically and who
try to expel the people who offend them
and what parties do those
your worldviews represent and then
that's very easy when you crystallize it
that way the what side is the losing
side but losing side right now is woke
divisa m-- activists left who have taken
over and the host which is the
democratic party to try to push that
worldview and it is really isolating and
you have a presidential candidate who
ODS on right now the betting world says
Bernie Sanders try and run an actual
communist to be in America and anything
Trump was that though it almost seems
like that's where we have to get to this
thing like to really kill this thing and
I did this post on New Year's Day that
went pretty viral about how this will be
the end year of the woke stuff it never
gets fully killed but I think this will
be the year that it fundamentally gets
crushed enough to change or or cause the
split in the DNC but it seems to me that
if you get the Trump Sanders thing then
that we can sort of put everyone can
just put all their cards out on the
table at that point right it's like it's
basically capitalism very socialism what
do you want people and the entire world
will by the way be voting for Trump
because nobody no sane person in any
other country wants America to become
socialist no oh yeah that's hard to
explain to people 3:00 in America for
summary this is why there's an open
there's open warfare right now on Bernie
open warfare Democrat establishment are
full of people who are investors who are
very wealthy who have made money off the
capitalist system and they do not want
to lose it all they do not want to give
it all away okay I'll do my crazy
Bloomberg theory my crazy Bloomberg
theory is that Bloomberg is running as
an insurance policy to ensure the Trump
wins I know that sounds nuts but the
idea being that if Bernie gets it
Bloomberg runs so that he can get maybe
5% of the decent Democrats the the
old-school liberals thus making sure
that Bernie loses because for as much as
Bloomberg hates Trump he at least likes
capitalism yes I know that sounds nuts
and he likes trade with China he likes
her good he likes that lane being oh
that trade lane being open yeah and yeah
Bernie does not i'll palea if if
Bloomberg does not
get the nomination and if he does not
become president he can still there's so
position open for him that he will be
beloved and cherished throughout the
land for and I think he's perfect for
which is playing baby Yoda in the knock
season of the mandalorian he's the
perfect size fit in the costume all
right
he's like the sensibility and I think he
has the sensibility to play baby Yoda
season two Mandalorian if you're if
you're out there okay listening to me
yeah yeah that might be a possibility
he'd be great that's a small small cute
yeah I know nobody likes being in the
prediction game but so I you think
Trump's just gonna run away with this
thing like like gangbusters kind of I'm
an optimist right but I'm also a realist
and you live in DC long enough you get
ya get real beaten down as a
conservative in DC over the last couple
cycles and then you look at the actual
data that is being produced right now
from swing states from the general
electorate and the same things that have
always been true or true still today in
the sense that people won't vote against
a thing that helps them the American
economy is doing better than it's done
perhaps in the history of this country
there is a lot of data to support that
and that certain groups that are
typically have a rough go are doing
better than they have ever done in the
history of this country and that people
will not vote against their own
interests and right now economically
things are just just going gangbusters
and so it just doesn't matter if Trump
kills General Grievous with a thermal
detonator the people are kind of people
are going to people are going to not
vote against their own self-interest is
there anything in the conservative
movement that you're not happy with at
the moment
the Conservatives missing anything are
they yeah coming up short yeah where
would that be or what would that be
there's still a there's still an inch
frenched establishment in the city that
likes communicating in the old way they
still like doing things the old way and
very much like media's going through
their own inception point and changing
drastically there is an establishment
there's an establishment conservative in
DC that we've read the headlines Trump
is always at odds with that like doing
things us their own way that way was
controlled decline and I hate that with
my there the very soul of my being so we
had control good decline that was
basically Jeb McCain Jeb Neal I can kind
of play by their rules but you lose it
we've lost the the the the world view
comes from this we've lost the culture
war we've lost the political landscape
war
we've lost the colleges we've lost the
education system we need to just control
the decline of our worldview and said
stop the boulder from rolling down the
hill on us a little bit if we can slow
it down it's a huge win right but it's
coming for us either way that's all
[ __ ] no that's not true and culture
is something that can be shifted on a
paradigm and can move quickly and if you
play it right and if you speak the
language that the new audiences of the
world are speaking then you can control
you can be the person who creates the
culture and who really does paradigm
shifts I mean look what Kanye's doing
right now inside of his industry dr. Dre
is gonna produce a Christian album with
Kanye you could we could do a whole show
I'm like whoa like all of the dimensions
there yeah my god that's a paradigm
shift and that's how that happened with
Trump we're for the first time in in my
lifetime and I was born in the last
years of Reagan first time in my
lifetime it wasn't about controlled
decline for conservatism
it wasn't about giving up and just
stopping the boulder from crushing us it
was about no we will move the boulder
back up the hill and we could put this
boulder back up on the hill and put our
enemies put the opposing side on their
hindquarters and roll it down on them
and make them fight us for territory and
so it's this I know it's a mean Dave I
get it but it literally is winning and
losing
I like winners they're losers it really
is winning and losing if you come at it
from a standpoint where you haven't lost
entirely I love that and guess what
that's what young people are attracted
to young people are attracted to people
who win they're attracted to winners
they're attracted to optimism they're
attracted your show for these exact
reasons and they rest in peace Kobe
Bryant I mean the guy was a winner
and in so many aspects of his life and
he exuded that optimism and he loved
America I found this whole viral clip of
him talking about being I shared it it's
amazing on Team USA and it's an amazing
he was even asked this was a couple
years ago he was asked like is that cool
to say America is the best country in
the world like it's cool for me people
are attracted to that right and there's
thousands down there's thousands of
people down like down at the Staples
Center right now because that attracted
people and for the first time in my life
conservatism kind of has that like that
that winning sensibility with all of our
new heroes and with New Avengers casts
of conservatives and the way that we are
conquering the Internet we are
destroying the left on the internet we
are winning the meme Moore's like it's
not the Clone Wars like we were winning
the level kami they cannot mean like we
are winning we are winning for the first
time it's very very exciting and so the
people who like controlled losing I
don't like that about modern
conservative sorry for the long answer
but like I really feel passionate about
this dude that's how you end an
interview no apology necessary
for those of you who are not on Twitter
you might want to follow at Benny
Johnson just for the memes but you put
them up on Instagram and all those other
places yeah yeah where the kids are yeah
yeah it was fun we'll have to do this
maybe we're gonna have to write a new
Star Wars story together oh my god is
that where this all heads yes yes I want
to with Bloomberg as baby with bloom
with Bloomberg as baby Yoda has anyone
done that I mean has anyone made that
where you put Bloomberg's head on baby
Yoda and done a little video I mean here
I'm handing you something okay I have to
go I have to go through that right now
that's gonna be right that's gonna be
the next thing I post that's gonna be
the next meme all right Bloomberg s baby
oh if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell